son unas elecciones bastante arriesgadas
especialmente para el primer ministro y
líder del partido liberal justin gritón
que buscará una reelección en canadá
tenemos una decisión que tomar como país
y realmente es una muy simple pero es
una muy importante seguimos avanzando o
retrocedemos con los conservadores
joe convocó elecciones anticipadas para
asegurar su mayoría en el parlamento y
lograr aprobar su plan de recuperación
económica después de la pandemia si los
sondeos parecían a su favor al momento
de tomar esta decisión la carrera no
está siendo tan fácil como pensaba las
encuestas siguen situándolo como
favorito según un sondeo de la radio
televisión pública canadiense cbc
youtube alcanza un 31.4 por ciento de
apoyo mientras que su principal
contrincante evín obtuvo tiene el 30.7
por ciento crudo quería unas elecciones
pandémicas de 600 millones de dólares
para obtener más poder no lo recompense
es el lunes vote conservador el
descontento de la población se atribuye
a los mandatos de vacunas contra el kobe
19 a una creciente preocupación por el
medio ambiente y al alza en el costo de
vida con la inflación más alta en 10
años el casi empate técnico actual deja
la nación en suspenso